he's been written off so many times and
despite
a momentous day for israeli politics and
an opposition which says it now
can form a government the man they call
the magician
may still hang on after four
inconclusive elections in just two years
opposition leader yaya lapid says he's
managed an unwieldy left
centre-right coalition a majority to
kick netanyahu out
but to secure that majority the
journalist and tv presenter turned
centrist politician
has had to promise the top job to
someone else
naftali bennett to netanyahu's right on
the political spectrum
is set to be israel's new prime
a minister 24 hours saw a new president
voted in two
but will this be the day remembered as
the moment that ever-present figure in
israeli
and global politics for three decades
was pushed out
his allies are certainly not writing him
off yet
well i i i will be cautious and i will
not start to
sum up his political career we have seen
in the past that he
he pulled out magics out of his sleeve
when people started to sum up
in korean and that magic will involve
what one person close to the
negotiations told me
will be days of hell netanyahu will chip
away at the coalition
trying to peel off individual
politicians to remove the majority
before the vote of confidence which will
probably be next week
since he was first elected in 1996 he
has been the consummate political
operator the survivor
the self-caste defender of the nation
where should a red line be drawn against
the iranians
the palestinians and the coronavirus
he's a whole football team from the
goalkeeper to the striker
on the pitch constantly fighting for
political survival and
anshul pfeffer is netanyahu's unofficial
biographer
i don't think this is the end of
netanyahu uh
even if this new government of
jail lapid and nathalie bennett and all
these other parties
from every part of the israeli political
spectrum
manages to somehow survive for the next
four years
and zenyatta will still be around he'll
still be the leader of liquids
if the netanyahu maneuvers fail and the
coalition holds it's unlikely any of its
individual party's more radical plans
will emerge
core issues like the israel-palestine
conflict will remain intransigent
but oddly netanyahu has succeeded in
creating an extraordinary unity against
him
on the left a secular centrist in the
middle a hard-line nationalist
and on the right an israeli arab all in
a coalition together
mark stone sky news in jerusalem